e aí pessoal tudo certo meu nome é
novidade eu tenho 14 anos sou inspirador
e eu sou empreendedor se espantando o
que será que dessa caixa dentro desta
caixa tem os segredos da minha
felicidade e hoje eu vou ter
e hoje eu vou mostrar para vocês alguns
dos segredos família pessoal família é a
base de tudo sem uma boa base
talvez você não consiga chegar onde você
quer chegar na minha família todos foram
primordiais para conseguir estar aqui
hoje cada um em seu papel fundamental
que a família composta por três irmãos
eu meu irmão mais velho tem nome de theo
ele tem 16 anos minha irmã mais nova que
a maria ela tem 11 anos e ela é do serra
faz crer que esses bons e outras coisas
para vender no colégio e há inclusive a
minha sócia uma das minhas empreitadas
de empreendedores
só que decidiu alçar vôos maiores
voltado
sabe de uma coisa que por mais seus pais
queiram por mais acesso às oportunidades
você tenha por mais dinheiro você tem
sua conta bancária em ninguém pode ter
com você
a vontade de fazer a sua parte
eu posso até ter tido acesso a tudo isso
que eu falei antes mas se não fosse a
minha vontade de empreender eu não
estaria aqui falando com vocês hoje
por isso a inspiração vem dos outros
já a motivação vem de dentro de você e
exibe a inspiração para empreender os
meus pais são os professores dos meus
melhores de todo mundo mas a vontade de
empreender ver dentro de mim
o raciocínio nós seres humanos
já nascemos com o melhor aplicativo do
mundo instalado o nosso corpo
o nosso cérebro com ele nós temos acesso
criatividade infinita
nós somos os únicos seres racionais do
planeta mas estamos fadados a ficar
atrás de uma mesa praticando trabalho
chatos e repetitivos
mas será que se a única opção não
pessoal essa não é a única opção
eles querem que vocês acreditem nisso
eles quem o mercado seus pais seus
professores a tv e internet
o sistema por completo o que é que você
acredita nisso mas essa não é uma opção
nós estamos muito acostumados a aceitar
tudo que nos é proposto seguir o fluxo
sem questionar
engoli tudo o que é colocado o ela baixo
pessoal é nós estamos vivendo o maior
índice de desemprego dos últimos cinco
anos
e você está procurando emprego fixo
muito obrigado pessoal coragem
o maior dos projetos é ter coragem de
tomar a decisão
eu recebi a educação empreendedora eu
nunca recebi mesada eu nunca é lá em
casa a educação 50 mais democracia
então eu sempre tive que correr atrás
para comprar as minhas coisas sempre
tive que lutar para ganhar um
dinheirinho é claro
e foi aí que quando eu sou empreendedora
eu descobri que havia vários caminhos
para seguir várias possíveis caminhos
para se ganhar vida
além de procurar emprego fixo foi que eu
tive que ter coragem de tomar minha
decisão de os seguir o fluxo na troca
embute estabilidade que estudar se
informar ter emprego fixo para garantir
o concurso para garantir a aposentadoria
ou empreender pessoal eu admiro muito
que segue pela ordem natural mas eu eu
quero muito mais que isso eu quero
aprender eu quero não me incomodar e
levantar todo dia sem emprego fixo e eu
quero ganhar dinheiro com o que eu gosto
de fazer
eu quero administrar variáveis família
amigos sonhos pra cá sucesso eu quero
renovar tem percepção em foco não apenas
empreender mas mostrar resultado pois o
que importa o pessoal é resultado
o resultado é muita coisa que pode fazer
as pessoas mudarem o que pensam sobre
você
o próximo segredo sonhos quem sonho é
porque é teimoso demais pra deixar o seu
futuro nas mãos do destino
todos os dias quando o código não tenho
mas voltando ao assunto
todos os dias quando acordo que ora meus
olhos eu penso duas coisas eu percebo
duas coisas a primeira é que eu não
consegui realizar duas moções que eu
queria ter realizado ontem e que nessa
noite eu tive vários sonhos novos e esse
é o fluxo que me faz seguir meus sonhos
todos os dias que me faz trabalhar feito
louco me faz correr atrás dos meus
sonhos
objetividade
tem história que eu gosto muito de
contar que fala da alice no país das
maravilhas alice ela corre à tarde o
coelho e caiu em um país desconhecido
chegando lá ela contra o gato e pergunto
gato onde estrada leva estou perdida eo
garoto responde depende para onde você
quer ir
e ela fala não sei eu estou perdido
novamente o garoto fala se você não sabe
para onde ir a qualquer lugar chegar
está bom então pessoal nessa história a
três personagens e eu não gostaria de
ser um dos três personagens o gato pois
exibe um sorriso falso e malicioso
o coelho que corre de um lado pro outro
relógio na mão mas isso é mas todos
chega atrasado dos locais e alice está
desorientada sobe nem de onde veio e
para onde vão esses três personagens
representam os três maiores ladrões de
felicidade e pessoal
é como disse existem os três já dói
ladrões de felicidade que é a ignorância
e medo e e outro que tem ea preguiça e
outro lado felicidade é a preguiça
pessoal daqui são os segredos da minha
felicidade
eu espero que esse segredo se encaixa
alguns dos segredos se encaixa para
vocês também pessoal
muito obrigada